[Aplausos]
[Música]
Pues yo ahora mismo Estoy rota porque le
conozco desde hace cinco años le he
visto muchos días Aquí venir a entrenar
los partidos y es una persona increíble
fuera y dentro del campo ahora mismo es
que yo creo que cuando salga me voy a
parar y llora
que no puedo
a ver el Real Madrid al final
es un club grande están los jugadores
van pasando le damos las gracias los
disfrutamos Pero al final sabíamos que
iba a llegar este momento ha tenido
una jugada temporada muy jugando muy
alto Muy alto ya se veía que ya le
costaba un poco seguir el ritmo y los
grandes saben retirarse cuando están
arriba
[Música]